researchers are not surprised waste
water testing is emerging as a go-to
method for finding covet 19. developers
of alberta systems say it detects covert
19 up to a week before positive cases
are confirmed clinically making it a
valuable tool in pandemic response
for example the
reinstatement of masking in calgary that
decision was informed in part by
wastewater testing and that really shows
that wastewater testing can be part of
the evidence base that policy makers use
to make these critical decisions in how
we navigate the pandemic not surprising
when you consider the virus survives a
long time in the gastrointestinal tract
and samples are contributed unknowingly
by everyone when they go to the bathroom
i think what we've seen in alberta is
that this technology really works
we had to iron out some kinks like other
teams across canada and around the world
it seems smoothing out some kinks is
ongoing a team that developed a
wastewater testing system at dalhousie
university raised eyebrows by claiming
it found the omicron variant in halifax
in mid-november weeks before it was
publicly reported in nova scotia even
before it was reported by south africa
but nova scotia's top doctor was not
convinced we've actually had
conversations with the the researchers
and what it turned out they were
detecting the alpha variant they
actually weren't detecting omicron so
it's still a research tool that has yet
to be validated in many ways dalhousie
university says the school stands by
their team's finding a statement from
the nova scotia government says a
different sample suggests the presence
of omicron but the finding has not been
confirmed as those test results are
tested
calgary researchers are flushed with
success their findings are posted online
as real-time data showing concentrations
of covet in various parts of the city
with wastewater testing methods evolving
researchers hope it helps canada detect
more threats to public health in future
covert 19 or others
ross lord global news halifax